RETO MEIER: Google
Cloud Next 2017
has hosted a rich array of talks
detailing the future of Cloud.
If you didn't get a chance to
catch Instant Insights, a GCP
developer's guide to building
real-time data analysis
pipelines, then stay tuned,
because here's the recap.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Google Cloud Platform
offers a variety of services
that you can use to analyze
high-volume continuous data
streams.
COLT MCANLIS: Fully
managed services,
such as Pub/Sub,
Dataflow, and BigQuery,
allow you to focus on generating
the insights you need,
rather than the distraction of
managing distributed systems.
RETO MEIER: For example, this
is a real-time visualization
of taxi rides in New York City.
The incoming data
stream is managed
by Pub/Sub, Google's
global publish
and subscribe service with
guaranteed at least once
message delivery.
This is a lot of data--
way too much to be processed and
visualized by our client device
directly.
To enable that, we need
to adjust the data stream
in a way that's more
manageable to the client.
COLT MCANLIS: That's where
Cloud Dataflow fits in.
Cloud Dataflow is a high-level
service and programming model
for pipeline data processing.
In our example, we need to
reduce the incoming stream
volume so the visualization
can display it
in real time, which
we can do by creating
a pipeline in Dataflow.
We start with an unbounded
collection of raw taxi data
from Pub/Sub, and then apply
a sequence of transforms.
First, we window the
data by time stamp,
and then we bucket by proximity.
This way, for each
window of time,
we can find taxis that
are near to each other.
Next, for each window
and location combination,
we count the number
of taxis and output
that as a new
collection via Pub/Sub.
RETO MEIER: For our needs,
we wrote a custom transform.
However, that's not always
the case, as Dataflow supplies
a number of standard transforms,
like windowing, mapping,
and count.
Both the incoming and outgoing
collections are unbounded,
so the pipeline will
run until the heat
death of the solar system,
until it's stopped,
or until someone spills
coffee on the entire internet,
all at once.
And because it is fully
managed, the back end
takes care of everything,
from optimizing the execution
graphs, spinning up VMs, staging
the pipeline code to the VMs,
managing I/O with Pub/Sub,
and managing persistent state
for full tolerance,
so you don't need
to think about any of that.
Instead, we can go straight
to the UI that shows us
how the pipeline is working.
Here, the volume
of our taxi stream
is reduced from roughly
20,000 MPS to roughly 2,000
MPS, which is low enough for
our visualizer to handle.
COLT MCANLIS: While Dataflow
can help process your data,
in order to gather
insights, you can
leverage Big Query,
Google's solution
for enterprise data warehousing.
Using Dataflow, we can create
one or more ETL pipelines
that ingest the
content into BigQuery,
allowing us to perform
queries and analysis.
For example, in addition
to the raw data,
we could also identify
rides to the airport,
and then run simple SQL queries
to compare the ride volume
and average fare between airport
taxis and the rest of New York,
not to mention the
time-based trends,
letting us know the best time
to catch a cab to the airport.
RETO MEIER: And this
is just a few examples
to inspire ideas about how you
can use these tools to gain
insights into your own data.
Check out the full
session video to learn
more about what you can
do with Cloud Dataflow,
as well as demos and
detailed examples
of generating instant insights
using New York City taxi data.
And if you want more recaps
on great Next content,
make sure to check out
the rest of our playlist.
And don't forget the next
world tour coming soon
to a city near year.
[MUSIC PLAYING]